- [Mark] All right, so beautiful.
- Hi.
- [Mark] Welcome back.
- Thank you for having me.
- [Mark] So you've got
lots of interesting things
that have happened since
the last time you were here?
- Yes I do.
- [Mark] Which has only been a few months.
- [Michelle] Right.
- [Mark] A couple months probably.
Tell me what's going on.
- I work for an independent
living home it's called
To Peace, from pain to pleasure
it was her idea for it.
The lady's name is Sibyl.
She's very nice, she's the owner.
She's given me a chance to work there.
I've got about, they upscaled me now.
I had nine pages now I have 13 today.
So I'm graduating, excelling.
- [Mark] So you're
working in a nursing home?
- It was independent living.
It's more apartments
that were turned into...
She brought this huge apartment
complex and each apartment
has either a patient and a
nurse or just a patient who's
able and capable of
taking care of themselves.
- [Mark] These are elderly people?
- A lot of elderly.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Or mostly like if you say
for instance if you got hurt
and you weren't able but you're
young and they don't have
a place for you and your
family can't deal with the type
of treatment you need.
Then they can put you there
too because independent living.
They kinda teach you how to
live independently if you can.
If you can't be living
independently then they try
to put a nurse in your
room with you, live in.
That's basically what it is.
They try to have everything on hand.
I started here now two
weeks ago I believe.
Actually it's two weeks today or tomorrow.
It's interesting, it keeps you very busy.
- [Mark] Yeah, you're
working like double shifts.
- Oh my God, it's crazy.
- [Mark] You told me
yesterday-
- And don't forget the fact
that if the clients are under
your name, if they call you
you've gotta go in.
It doesn't matter.
I feel like a doctor.
- [Mark] Yeah, you told me
yesterday you've just finished
a shift and then you had
to go to another one-
- Yeah, the lady fell.
- [Mark] Your boss called you and
- I am like okay-
- So your boss loves
you 'cause you're like-
- I'm always there.
- [Mark] You're ready,
willing and able to work.
- All the time.
I'm not gonna stop.
I love it, I'm starting at $17 an hour.
Can't complain about that.
Going from street walking to that.
- [Mark] So what got
you to make that change?
- Kind of this, doing this
someone is interested.
My daughters, my 16-year-old
daughter got pregnant,
I have another granddaughter.
- [Mark] You have kids
you're raising as well?
- Huh.
- [Mark] You have kids
that you're raising?
- Yes, I do.
- [Mark] So you're not-
- I'm not out the water yet.
So it's hard because I've already got six.
My sister died so I've
got my niece and my nephew
that I have to take care of
too 'cause they're just still
kinda loopy over that.
My niece has, oh my God, four
kids herself and she's only 24
and my nephew he doesn't
have any kids yet.
He's trying to finish college.
I just feel like this was
a positive move for me.
I really needed it.
I was done...
Woo, how do you say?
I felt like I was the
influence of my daughter having
a baby because some way somehow
they always see what we do
or they know and they're
like progeny innocence to me.
You know they can always feel
their parents no matter what.
You know what I mean?
So I feel like I played a part
in that for not being there
and now that I have them
around me I just had
to send them somewhere.
I needed a break 'cause I
couldn't focus on my new job
and all of them.
And then my daughter has
a dog at the hospital.
She works in radiology.
So neither one of us and we're the oldest,
she's 26 and I'm 44.
That's my oldest kid.
So we're pretty much
gone most of the time.
So then I've got my 16 and
my 14, you know what I mean?
Kind of man in the house, that's not good.
- [Mark] Some of the
kids are living with you
and some are-
- Right,
so I sent six of them off to New Jersey
the day before yesterday.
- [Mark] Temporarily or permanently?
- Temporarily, oh no, I love my babies.
(Michelle laughs)
The older ones left with,
let me see one, two, three.
They took Andrina's kids and
they took one of my grandkids
which was my son's son.
And I still have Zumaya with me.
Well, she is my granddaughter.
Her name is beautiful too.
(Michelle chuckles)
So it's family planning coming together.
I think my kids are
happier now to be around me
than they were because I was in and out.
It just was non-stop.
My daughter was kind of
embarrassed to have me
but she's coming around now.
She's actually calling me
mom now instead if Michelle.
She always did say,
"Michelle, what do you want?"
Now she's like mom.
- [Mark] So working in the
streets makes it a very difficult
lifestyle to lead.
(Michelle groans)
- [Michelle] Like they
feel like you're not a part
of them at all.
I really get hit in the heart big time.
My oldest daughter she's
gonna definitely make sure
I feel it.
She's just like, "What
do you want Michelle?"
And I'm like, "Wow,
first name basis really?
I had you little girl."
She's like, "I'm not a
little anymore I'm grown."
You're still my kid.
But they're smiling more now.
She calls me a lot more
now so I don't feel like
a big let down.
I'm gonna keep this going
until they either elevate me
or I make something out of it.
It's a blessing.
Thank you Lord.
And I've got a good
support system behind me
and I've got good people trying
to come into my life now.
So losing my parents, losing
my sister it's just me
and my baby brother and I
still haven't even seen him.
So I guess from the last (indistinct).
(Michelle laughs)
- [Mark] So me making the
transition from working the street
and figuring out how to doing
this is not easy, right?
- It's not easy at all.
Even doing this interviews and stuff...
The gentlemen can I see your name?
- [Mark] Sure.
- Okay.
(people laughing)
Well, Mark's been
helping out a great deal.
I mean there's a lot of things
that coming from the streets
and then getting into the
job I'm not making money.
- [Mark] Yeah, you haven't been paid yet?
- At all, so it's kind of like...
I get paid this Friday,
yay so I have something
to brag about.
I'm building steps right now
so every time like if I need
my ID Mark's been there for me
and you're really highly appreciated.
You have no freaking clue.
- [Mark] Or your car or your whatever.
- Yeah, mostly everything.
Bills rent and-
- [Mark] But I gotta say it's really-
- It's paying off though.
- [Mark] It's really rewarding
being able to help somebody-
- It is, to have someone
intercede when you can't do
for self-
- [Mark] Yeah,
but from my side of the fence
it's really rewarding to help
somebody who's helping themselves.
- And I love you for it.
- [Mark] Aggressively.
Like I see you working,
you were working all night-
- Literally, I got home at.
- [Mark] You work night
shifts, you work morning,
you work day you know seven
days a week you're working
- I got home at two.
And had to go right back out
at four and then they let me
off early like a 30 to
45 minutes and I go home.
I mean no sooner I went to
sleep the phone was ringing
again I'm like, "Jude, you
guys serious there's nobody on-
- [Mark] So my experience in
helping whether it's somebody
on skid row or it's the girls-
- Right, your motivation is great and-
- [Mark] A lot of them
the drugs come into play
and it really changes the whole thing.
- That's my thing.
I'm kinda seeing that.
- And your drug-free?
- Drug-free, baby.
- [Mark] Yeah.
You pretty much always have been, right?
- Yeah, I smoke cigarettes
though, bad habit.
- [Mark] Yeah, but-
- As far as hard drugs no, I'm done.
- [Mark] Everyone else I'm
dealing with the drugs come
into play and it really
changes the interaction.
It changes the way to help.
- Even their attitude.
- [Mark] Their help becomes
enabling very quickly.
- Their attitude becomes different.
- [Mark] And With you I see
that my help is truly helping.
- It's rewarding, it's healthy
and it's actually getting me,
it keeps me going.
It lets me know that,
"Okay, he's helping me now
but I'll be able to help
myself later," and I'll be able
to pay back somebody that has
stuck their neck out for me,
which that's my goal so
don't think you're not
thought about.
- [Mark] Will see about that.
I'm not holding you to that.
- I know but it's my goal.
You never asked me for anything
back, you've actually been
a reward in my life that I
never thought I could even have.
- [Mark] Well, I mean from
my side it's just so nice
'cause you're one out of
2,600 people you're like one
of about three or four people
who have really taken the ball
and done the right thing.
- And I appreciate the compliment.
- [Mark] 'Cause you're
as solid as you appear.
- Thank you, I appreciate that.
- [Mark] 'Cause now you and I
have gotten to know each other
and I see how incredibly
responsible you are,
how hardworking you
are, how honest you are.
You're always doing the
right thing for yourself,
for your kids and your
employer and me and everybody.
- I appreciate that.
- [Mark] And it's just been
delightful to interact with you.
- Thank you Mark, I surely appreciate it.
- [Mark] You're amazing.
I think the world of you.
- Thanks.
(Beautiful laughs)
- [Mark] So do you miss working fig?
(Mark laughs)
I'm sure you know.
- Not really, only when I don't
have money I kind of think
about it like I gotta go get groceries.
I'm not gonna wanna call you all the time
because you're just like an
intercessor but then when I go
outside on the street
and I'm just like this
is so not it anymore
- [Mark] But it's...
What are the emotions that
that lifestyle gives a woman?
- Stress, belittling,
sometimes you feel like
you're Miss It.
You become very promiscuous but I got...
I'm more anti-social than I was.
I don't even want people to really see me
that I've ever been with.
- [Mark] Is that shame?
- Very much so.
I feel it...
I have a high sex drive
anyways though but to slow down
and not even trip on the streets.
Like one day I am gonna have a partner,
someday but it will happen
and I wanna be able to clean
myself off mentally and
physically and spiritually
to where I don't have to
balance that option out
in my relationship.
And I do not want my partner
to ever think I'm gonna
run back off and because I'm
not getting enough at home
or whatever I'm gonna go to the streets.
I'm not that promiscuous.
I'm not a nympho I just like
what I like but other than that
everything's going good.
And I'm thankful for the opportunity
from my employer as well.
- [Mark] Yeah, your employer
sounds really great too.
(Michelle whistles)
- Yeah, I mean it took
me a lot of applications,
a lot of checking and this
is actually something that's
heart calming because
of the type of people
I'm dealing with.
- [Mark] Doing honest work?
- [Michelle] Honest work
and it's very heart calming
'cause trust me my life was-
(Michelle blows)
so now you have to take
time with these patients.
- [Mark] But do you feel
like the shame is fading away
and-
- A little bit.
Not much yet because I know
some of these people in this
building have been out and
they've seen me and they're like,
"I seen you before," I'm like ,"Where?"
- [Mark] But you're changing your story.
You're doing it by yourself.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I'm very proud of you darling.
- [Michelle] Thank you very much.
I truly appreciate you.
- [Mark] You're amazing.
- [Michelle] All right.
- [Mark] Keep it up.
- [Beautiful] Most definitely.
(people laughing)
- [Mark] All right, thank you Michelle.
- [Michelle] All right.
- Yeah, that's cool.
- [Mark] So proud of you.